why do you think infidelity occurs most
commonly in your experience I would
honestly say if you ever get cheated on
I always I know people hate me for this
but it's usually your fault and the
reason I say that particularly with men
uh a cheating woman shows you every red
flag from day one if you choose to
ignore red flags you'll pay the price in
life you pay prices there's price taxs
now everybody shows you that the
cheaters show you they're going to be a
cheat and how they show it is very
simple their values they maybe they show
you that they've done it in the past
maybe they show you that they are not so
traditional maybe they show you that
they are don't believe in monogamy May
they're addicted to pornography cheaters
show you their their past they show you
everything now if you don't want to get
cheated on you either choose that
cheater but know what know what the
score is and then you don't get hurt you
know what's going to happen but ignoring
red flags is always going to get land
you in that position now whenever I have
clients that have been cheated on a lot
for five six years A man's got another
mistress or three years she's still been
talking to her ex I was like there's no
way she can get to 3 years without your
you consenting and they're like what do
you mean by that I was like they would
have been late replies there would have
been days their phones are off there
would have been not telling you where
they're going they tell you everything
their social media would have suggested
something you would have been
questioning them sometimes and they
would have got defensive rather than
reassuring you they would have been
signs you chose to ignore them the price
you pay for that unfortunately is
infidelity so you either accept an
Unfaithful know what you're there doing
and then just decide okay I can accept
it but I'd rather be with you than not
without you but you but denying the red
flags is always it's going to catch up
on you the infidelity is going to occur
so that's why people get cheated on why
people choose to do it is because they
can get the comfort of a relationship
with the joy and pleasure of a an
alternative connection so they get two
in one so they might get the comfort of
somebody who pays a bills but the sex
life of a young personal trainer that
she wants and he might get the comfort
of a good wife but then the sexual
experience of a escort when he goes and
does that so they we become so greedy we
don't realize that some things have to
involve a s a sacrifice a healthy
marriage has to involve sacrificing the
Alternatives we don't see the need to
sacrifice Alternatives because now we
are so gluttonous even if we eat a lot
we can still do that and get surgery
even if we spend a lot we can still get
credit cards we no longer see the
sacrifice of Alternatives is required in
order for positive outcomes yeah there's
a a cool quote that says
uh there are
no there are no options only trade-offs
right that for everything that you want
there is something else that you need to
give up and I think that's a good way to
look at relationships yeah if you want a
good healthy marriage unfortunately you
might have to sacrifice the most
exciting sexual experience every day of
your life because that's what 20 years
of marriage doesn't look like you know
it's realistic and if you want like a
single life then you have to accept that
your emotional like you might suffer
from anxiety and depression in the long
run so you've got to realize whatever
decision you make it comes with a lot of
pain and suffering pick your pain being
married the pain might involve being
bored it might not being sexually
stimulated but being single the pain
might involve a lot of loneliness
depression and sadness just pick which
pain you can handle and confine yourself
to that decision and ward off all the
Alternatives what do you think about
getting back together after infidelity
um get back together absolutely you I
don't if there's children I don't say no
way no way no way if there's no children
I always tell people to reconsider um
but one thing I would say it's different
from men and women when a man forgives a
female CH she can't respect you the same
way you got to remember we like Alpha
men Alpha men don't accept promiscuity
so what happens when you accept a woman
back a part of her will always feel like
you're weak and you don't have the
willingness to walk away because there's
nothing that can push a man to walk away
more than infidelity and if that didn't
do it nothing will so now she's Lawless
for a man again I don't re massively
recommend it unless there's children but
I would focus more on what was the
meaning behind the affair what were they
seeking and if it's something that you
can do in your marriage by all means do
it but if it's something that's more
traumatic and it's more to do with an
emptiness and a trauma in their
childhood and you can't feel that void
then you still can get back with them
but expect the behavior to continue when
I when people get back together of fair
I just say but ask yourself if he stayed
exactly the same and still cheated 5
years down the line could you be okay
with it and if you decide you know what
I can as long as you're good to me and
good to the kids I can do it by all
means do it but don't go back together
expecting it to be completely different
it's not it's not realistic interesting
to think that one of the considerations
that you're focusing on to do with
infidelity is not whether the person can
accept that themselves it's whether the
other person can accept being accepted
especially for women yes so essentially
can can you accept worst case scenario
if worst case scenario happens again can
you accept it if the answer is no then
you're just delaying the divorce just do
it now if the answer is yeah because the
alternative I just don't want to do it
then go ahead but always ask yourself
can I accept worst case scenario then if
that happens at least you've prepared
for it if it doesn't happen at least
your marriage stands a shot it's a
brutal realization I guess for guys that
maybe they're partner may have had
infidelity and then they can
try and do the work to be able to accept
them again but that is creating a rhythm
A vibe that may make it difficult for
the partner that cheated on them to to
accept them back again yeah something
dies in us when you accept the
unacceptable because your masculinity is
depleted and the other thing is the man
loses his masculinity he starts to hate
himself for not being able to walk away
instead of having a pride of attached to
like okay I've kept my family together
they know they shouldn't do it there's
something speaks to them so they end up
hating themselves and because they can't
always express that they can get quite
hostile and violent towards a woman and
can get quite verbally abusive towards
her and I'm not saying she's like an
angel but the verbal abuse and it's all
you're doing is like I said you're just
essentially punishing her for your
inability to walk away she's going to
beg and say please forgive me please
forgive me but the reality is um we
don't want the man that forgives us we
really don't we want the man that says
you had your chance it's been a pleasure
I wish you the best because that's a man
we
respect why do married women
cheat um a lot of married women a couple
of reasons they didn't marry the person
they truly wanted to marry they the
biological clock hit them and they
married who was available at the time
and they might have had an ex that they
idolized they might have had something
else that they didn't marry correctly
they didn't choose the person that they
wanted to marry they chose a person who
wanted to marry them and so they settled
to begin with so they started wrong and
that can happen on the alternative side
it could be is when she hasn't felt
desired for a really long time and she
puts the feeling of needing to feel
desired and sexy and attractive as a
number one like uh emotion so she'll put
that over and above her family and she
craves that so if she's naturally born
like quite attention seeking or if she
married who who wanted to marry her
rather than who she really wanted to
marry unfortunately she's more prone to
cheating yeah and and you and also if
she grew up with a bit of chaos I find
that women that come from single parent
homes are far more likely to cheat and
the reason I I've noticed that and the
the only hypothesis I can think of is
that usually when somebody isn't
fulfilling our needs we can go back to a
safe haven of two we we're designed to
have two parents that love us we got Mom
and Dad two people love us that's how it
should be now when those two people one
of them is absent you always feel like
there's a void so when you're in a
relationship and all of it is on him if
he stops giving you that love you almost
seek it as a backup because you don't
want that emptiness that you may have
experienced as a child so they almost
have a backup before they can leave the
guy they can't just leave and be by
themselves because that really feels
lonely they'd rather leave when they've
got somebody else it's like having that
extra parent in your life you you like
when you have Mom that anoy you've
always got dad youve got a backup but
when you didn't grow up with that that
being by yourself is really horrible and
Lonesome so they always if one person's
lets them down they always try and keep
back up in case that person removes
their love from them it's a safety hatch
safety hatch yeah what about men why do
men cheat um men usually cheat when
they're chasing an ego boost they're not
usually in love with the person that
they're cheating with but they are in
love with the feeling that person gives
them and sometimes the person makes them
feel seen sometimes the person makes
them feel like they're fed sometimes
they feel person makes them feel
attractive whatever it is heard um
they're chasing a particular feeling
that they're deprived of either from
their marriage or from their childhood
and as a result they seek it it's not
sexual people think it's just oh they
men love sex men love sex there's some
men out there if they really love sex
they would just have sex with their
wives they haven't had sex with their
wives in a long time but they crave
novelty or they crave somebody else
making them feel a certain way so I
don't think it's all sexual I think it's
far more psychological and emotional
than they think it is and they label it
as sex but really it's the new person is
get making them feel seen and maybe they
felt unseen for a really long time at
home and I suppose that a lot of single
people people or escorts are
purposefully portraying a version of
themselves that makes that person feel
seen yeah the escorts know exactly what
they're doing same with sugar babies
they know that with this man who's been
married for so long they target married
men because they have a in my experience
of what I watching them what they do is
they have a leverage because every time
he doesn't pay her he can say I'm going
to tell your wife so they really do
Target married men because they've got
that leverage but also the the low
self-esteem in married men it's so easy
to manipulate them giving them a phone
call to tell them that they look great
tell them that they smell great telling
that there coffee ready they haven't
heard these phrases in a really long
time and that works perfectly with
married men but it doesn't work so much
with a man who's been on the single
scene for so long and has four or five
different girls coming over every month
or whatever it is so because everybody's
foring over him in the same way yeah so
you don't stand out to that guy we'll
get back to talking to sard in one
minute but first I need to tell you
about Factor if you are too busy this
Autumn to cook but still want to make
sure that you're eating well Factor fact
is the solution with Factor you can skip
the extra trip to the grocery store plus
all of the chopping and prepping and
cleaning up while still getting the
flavor and nutritional quality that you
need Factor fresh never frozen meals are
ready in Just 2 minutes so all you have
to do is heat and enjoy and right now
that Autumn menu has some absolute
bangers like a cranberry peacan chicken
and an apple Dijon pork chop or if like
me you're struggling to hit your protein
girls you can try their Protein Plus
meals with 30 G or more of protein per
serving I cannot tell you how big of a
life hack it is to only be 2 minutes
away from a 30 g of protein meal at all
times right now you can get 50% off by
heading to the link in the description
below or going to factor meals.com
mw50 using the code mw50 a checkout
that's factor meals.com
mw50 and mw50 a checkout what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to
subscribe